the New York Times Reporter asked
recently he's like why don't they just
do them by Zoom they take you know it's
like 30 000 people it's all this energy
of course every time they have them
there's all these stories about
all the private jets that fly and arrive
there in the hypocrisy of it um
but I kind of was joking you know why
why don't we do the Hajj over Zoom you
know why don't you have a pilgrimage you
know over zoom and the reason it's a
pilgrimage it's a religious event
it's not it shouldn't be understood as
an event that will decide how Nations
what how they use energy or how they use
food that's the conceit of the people
who attend those meetings but these are
people often who are activists they're
politicians these are people that don't
really understand how electrical grids
work or energy systems work they go
there and they're kind of in a
journalists are there they also don't
understand this the activists are there
they have very little to do with like
real world decision making so that's why
I kind of go it's just a festival of
narcissism there's no point in
even talking about it